In particular we're going to focus
on two problems that DAC has.
The first problem is that
although the owner of a resource,
owner of a file let's say, owner happens
to be Alice, controls who this file
can be shared with, and Alice gives
Bob access to read this file.
The problem arises because Alice
is not going to be able to control
if the information is going to
stay with her and Bob only.
So the problem is, can Bob share this
information further with somebody else?
One problem that we have here with
the DAC model is that although we can
control direct access to our files,
but how that information can be shared
with others we're not able
to fully control that.
In particular, this problem is called
the information flow control problem.
So information was shared with Bob,
flows from Alice to Bob, but
can it flow further?
And in the Discretionary Access Control
model we're not able to control this
flow going from Bob to Charlie.
There is another problem that
Discretion Access Control has and
this is because of the idea that
resource is owned by the user and
it is at his discretion
who it can be shared with.
Well, in many organizations at companies
it's really not at your discretion.
You are an employee of a company and the
company actually controls how certain
type of data should be shared in
that company or outside of that.
In other words,
the employer of the company
where the user works actually
may be able to mandate or
will mandate actually how certain
kinds of sensitive data can be shared.
So to address these two problems,
we actually going to explore
another model for access control.
It's called the Mandatory Access Control
model and it's called
Mandatory Access Control because it
is not at the discretion of the user.
Discretionary Access Control is at the
discretion of the owner of a resource.
But here organization is going to
mandate how data can be shared and
that's why it's called
Mandatory Access Control.